this question Anthony comes from Daniel
in Arizona Dave Anthony I'm on baby step
- I've got 27,000 and student loan debt
1,500 in a personal loan 800 on credit
cards since the corona virus pandemic I
noticed my student loans have gone from
eight-and-a-half 2% interest to zero
should I stop paying my credit cards and
focus on my student loans since they
have no interest or should I keep paying
off the smaller debt being my credit
cards and personal and then my student
loans I'm a I think he already knows the
answer but I help him out again you know
we're not gonna stop we're not gonna
stop the debt snowball
okay we're going to continue working it
that $800 me honestly I will give him
more aggressively after that right now
in CV from 800 to 1500 depending on your
income and then go after the student
loan that resident 800 know something at
1500 then you know let's just knock it
out yeah just not only 0.3 hundred bucks
get those two things done and then get
after those student loans the thing is
the interest that you're saving on the
student loans not having to pay that is
going to work either way mathematically
it's going to end up in exactly the same
place if you pay the exact same amount
so there's no math benefit and you knock
out the little ones because you get that
get to pat yourself on the back get to
say attaboy yes well done well done
Daniel in Arizona well done you get to
keep going and then you tear into that
student loan and even if it is zero
interest we're gonna pay it off as fast
as we possibly can the fact that they've
given you an interest break only
accelerates how fast you pay it off it
does not mean you stop paying on them
exactly exactly Dave I mean I think
that's that's golden don't break the
baby steps you guys don't break the
death snowball I mean the only thing
we're telling you is like we've always
told you if you're in the middle of a
crisis yourself a personal crisis of
income or financial you do not work the
baby steps you stop and build up cash so
if you've lost your job in the pandemic
yeah if you have been furloughed in the
pandemic then you're in the middle of a
crisis you stop everything and use pile
up cash and take care of your four walls
food
utilities rent being your first three
and transportation keep gas in the car
and to go to your new job that you start
working to get things going again yeah
as soon as possible I mean take anything
just keep going keep money coming in
don't it's real easy in a situation
where there's there's a lot of excuses
out there that are disguised as reasons
yeah to sit and wait on something to
happen let me tell you when something is
going to happen when you make something
happen that's it
the government sending you twelve
hundred dollars that is not gonna fix
your life and if it did by definition
you were already struggling
mathematically if twelve hundred otters
fixes your life mathematically you
didn't have a life and so it doesn't fix
your life it's a joke
and so you got a lot bigger everybody's
got a lot bigger problems and Anthony
you experienced it this week where the
mortgage companies offering perfectly
healthy people financially healthy
people the right to go into forbearance
and delay their payments which is going
to create a mess on down the road yes
it's called a forbearance plan and when
I went to pay my mortgage payment that
lady said well hey we are offering
forbearance for three months and I was
like well really I said okay give me a
little more information about that I
still pay my bill but I just wanted to
ask questions just for knowledge and she
said yes all you gonna do is just you
know push off for three months and then
at the end of that forbearance plan I'm
all three months plus the current month
will all be due at one time so if your
payment is two thousand dollars a month
for an example that means you're paying
eight thousand dollars and one lump sum
how does that help people that doesn't
help people at all no it just delays the
foreclosure it's frustrating even if
even if you're in a crisis situation I
mean if you if you push one payment
until you get things going then catch it
right back up that's all you can do
whereas you're broke then that's all you
can do but it you know this kicking the
can down the road stuff these SBA loans
for these small businesses that are
supposedly forgiving and I got to tell
you I've been reading the details on it
and I think you guys are stepping up on
a rug over the top of an empty manhole
yeah you come fall right straight
through and find yourself in the sewer
but Dave let's talk about that a
government said we're going to forgive
something what haven't we already had
this conversation over in the student
loan world are there a lot of people
saying hey you know I thought I was
gonna get my loans forgiven because I
work in this certain area but then they
found out
well hey you didn't make this kind of
payment or you didn't do this or you
didn't actually go to this particular
area so not the checkbox for a loan they
come on and when you forget forex come
on you don't check the box oh I'm so
sorry it's a loan now and don't tell me
it's a grant it is not a grant it's all
alone and you have to meet very
stringent guidelines on hiring firing
maintaining your payroll small
businesses for that loan to be forgiven
this is the SBA they're the DMV of small
business you're about to get yourself in
a crack people do not do this do not to
kick your can down the road with these
forbearances do not kick the can down
the road with a supposed forgiveness and
you're making a good point I mean
haven't we heard this song before same
song different verse yes sir I'm from
the federal government and I'm here to
help
what is it should make your hair curl
right there when you hear that phrase
I'm telling you there's 88,000 people
right now where they has our curling
because they thought there was going to
get their student loans forgiven that
have been turned down yes and they've
only approved a handful a handful just
like just five or some introduced
ridiculous research student loan
forgiveness not happening and you'll
find it's true it's not happening that's
what you're gonna get then you're gonna
find out the borrower's slave to the
lender and that master is not very
forgiving that's what you're gonna find
don't do that and don't kick the
forbearance down the road ain't stay off
the payday lenders lie please don't I'm
sorry I've seen it yesterday Dave 13
cars I'm just gonna say it on taking a
license plate number
no but 13 cars at advanced financial
like and I'm like what are you all doing
this this is not the smart move you guys
they're gonna charge you ridiculous
interest rate and what's going to happen
you and get stuck in this four years and
four years in three years because if you
don't have the money now what makes you
think you're gonna have the money when
you do get your job back or when it is
next week you're gonna get stoned and
you can get 3 jobs delivering pizza by
the end of the night yes you can get
jobs with Amazon you can get jobs with
grocery stores they're hiring like crazy
Amazon's got a hundred thousand jobs
I've launched now is that a job you want
to do is your career for the next 25
years no no we're not trying to get
through the next 25 years we're getting
through the next 25 days if you don't
have a job but if your jobs ok just God
stay away from the stupidity because
this stuff let me tell you it always
feels good in the short term it always
releases the pressure in the short term
and it always makes a bigger mess in the
long term and that's what tells you when
you're doing something dumb with money
and so you do not have to fall into this
and we're not here to say oh you should
have had an emergency fund I told
yourself oh you should have been out of
debt I told you so we're not saying that
well if you're hurting we're here to
help you but we're also telling you if
you're hurting don't get don't you know
you know don't break your finger and end
up breaking both your legs as a result
please though that's just your your
cutting off your nose to spite your face
thing don't do that
check out Financial Peace University at
Dave Ramsey comm slash
hope we are for the first time in 30
years giving you a free 14-day trial
some of you have 14 days left at home
and you've got a free 14-day trial for
the full high performance suite the nine
weeks of classes it's nine classes so
you can easily binge through those
easier than you can some of the stuff
you're doing on Netflix yeah and every
dollar plus you get it all signed up you
can get everything going for Financial
Peace University spread the word
Financial Peace University free for 14
days people need to be in this over
30,000 people have already done it in
just the last couple of weeks and we
want a bunch more in there I'm on a
three hundred thousand doing this
and then I'll be happy